if I were king of the food is we would
have math in the core curriculum I mean
science would be in the core curriculum
English in the core curriculum
elementary science is where you get
scientists everybody in the space
program everybody who's a doctor got
interested in science when he or she was
seven or eight years before they're ten
not when they were 16 or 18 that's where
you spend your money is science
education in elementary levels now
people are opposed to core curriculum I
believe for two reasons one of them good
and the other just not the first reason
I Bullitt my perception is they are
afraid having these core curricula these
standards prohibits teachers from having
time to do other stuff that they're good
at takes away from other things that a
teacher brings to the party and by that
I mean what is your favorite thing about
your favorite teacher and it's his or
her passion it's his or her like I'm so
excited about this I want you to get
excited about this when you're a little
kid when you're any do at any level even
if you're 58 year old guy going to the
Smithsonian to take a course in
oceanography for fun it's the passion of
the person presenting that gets you
going so by having too many standards
that have to be met to rigorously the
concern is and I understand this that
you'll keep students from having any fun
and getting excited about anything but
the other reason people seem to my
perception of what people don't like
about core curricula is it forces them
to learn standard stuff when they could
be teaching their kids things that are
inconsistent with what we know about
science I'm talking about people that
want to teach creationism instead of
biology and that's just bad I mean and
the excuse or the justification is you
don't want the government telling you
what to do we all have to learn the
alphabet
everybody okay that's just I'm sorry
that's just we're going to have a
successful Society it's not an arbitrary
arrangement of letters it's you've got
to learn it sorry in the same way if
you're asking me everybody's got to
learn a little bit of physics chemistry
mathematics and you got to learn some
evolution you got to learn some biology
I mean the idea is obvious right you
have certain minima that everybody's got
to meet what everybody's got to learn to
the alphabet everybody's got to learn to
read the US Constitution is written in
English so everybody's got to learn to
read English it'd be great if you learn
some tonal languages some Romance
language that'd be good but our laws are
written in English everybody's got to
learn read English everybody's got to
learn math everybody's got to learn some
algebra everybody's got to learn some
biology including evolution and it's so
what's not to love but I know there are
people who posted